تغطيه اعلاميه كبيره لمعركه الامير هاري
القضائيه ضد ناشر صحيفه ديليمرر وادعاء
خرق خصوصيته في حمله لفضح مخالفات الصحافه
الشعبيه البريطانيه من اجل انقاذها كمهنه
وفق زعمه
الامير هاري هو اول افراد العائله الملكه
يدلي بشهادته في المحكمه منذ 130 عاما
وبعد اداء القسم استهل محامي دفاعي مجموعه
الصحف ميرور اندروغرين بسؤال الامير هاري
فيما يتعلق مقالات قال انها تستند الى
موده تم الحصول عليها بشكل غير قانوني
اعدائه للصحافه كان واضحا في الرد على
اسئله هيئه الدفاع الصحيفه من رمي اللوم
عليها في الحاجه التي اودت بحياه والدته
ديانا الى ما عاناه من اضطراب مع عائلته
واصدقائه من خلال جمع معلومات لمقالاتها
عن طريق الخداع وانشطه غير مشروعه متسائلا
عن علاقه اموره الشخصيه بالمصلحه العامه
التي شكلت كيف ينظر اليه من قبل عامه
الناس
شاهدا فحسب بل انه ايضا المدعي في هذه
القضيه وما يجعلها محاكمه ضخمه انه احد
افراد العائله الملكه وابن الملك تشارلز
يخوض معركه قضائيه ضد احد اكبر ناشر الصحف
بريطانيا
يوم ثان من التدقيق في مضمون ادعاءات
مبرمج في جلسه المحاكمه التاريخيه لكن
قرار الحكم النهائي في قضيته سيتطلب سنوات
لقناتي العربيه والحدث مصطفى زارو لندن
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات